gestern hat die bereits über die
fragwürdige studie des virologen
christian drosten berichtet es gibt
große zweifel an seinen
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnissen und
mittlerweile nun auch mehr
stellungsnahmen er gilt als der virologe
und in der korona krise als wichtiger
berater der kanzlerin professor
christian drosten
seine erkenntnisse über das corona virus
sie waren mitentscheidend für alle
regierungsentscheidungen in der korona
krise doch bild recherchen ergeben jetzt
drosten lag nach ansicht auch seine
eigenen wissenschaftler mit seiner
wichtigsten corona studie komplett
daneben
es geht um diese studie am 29 april
veröffentlicht durch das institut für
virologie an der berliner charité leiter
dieses instituts professor christian
drosten wichtigste frage der studie
können sich kinder genauso leicht mit
corona anstecken wie erwachsene und die
kosten studie kommt zu diesem ergebnis
kinder können genauso ansteckend sein
wie erwachsene
der dringende appell der forscher
deshalb an die politik aufgrund dieser
ergebnisse müssen wir vor einer
unbegrenzten wiedereröffnung von schulen
und kindergärten in der gegenwärtigen
situation warnen
doch jetzt werfen wissenschaftler aus
zahlreichen ländern den charité vorstand
vor unsauber gearbeitet zu haben
selbst in bostons forscherteam wird
diese kritik geteilt professor leonhard
hält zum beispiel vom institut für
epidemiologie biostatistik und
prävention uni zürich kritisiert die
erkenntnisse müssen mit einiger vorsicht
interpretiert werden
statistik professor dominik liebl von
der uni bonn sagt die statistische
analyse der autoren widerspricht ihrer
zentralen schlussfolgerung und
wirtschafts professor jörg steuer von
der renommierten cornell university in
new york sagt meine leser der charité
studie kehrt ihre stoßrichtung um kinder
also nicht genauso sondern weniger
ansteckend und die kern kritik der
wissenschaftler
für die studie wurden zu wenige kinder
untersucht interessant drosten im fall
der ministerpräsidenten konferenz unter
leitung von kanzlerin angela merkel
schulen und kitas bundesweit zu
schließen bereits am 13 märz
boston selbst wollte sich zu seiner
studie nun auf bild anfrage nicht äußern
und twitterte stattdessen lediglich er
habe besseres zu tun dann genau darüber
möchte ich jetzt sprechen mit meinem
kollegen philipp jakob philipp du hast
über die fehler in der studie berichtet
was sagst du jetzt zu den vorwürfen das
bild einen der mathematiker die auch
mitgearbeitet haben jetzt in die irre
geführt hätte ja also im bild artikel
steht dass die kritik der eben genannten
professoren auch im forschungsteam von
professor thorsten geteilt wird das
stimmt auch
professor torsten selbst hat sich dazu
auf twitter geäußert und mir unterstellt
dass ich einen englischsprachigen
mathematiker in die irre geführt habe
bei einem telefongespräch
dem muss ich widersprechen das ist nicht
der fall
der besagt englischsprachige
mathematiker wusste jeder zeit mit wem
er spricht er hat nachgefragt von
welcher zeitung ich bin ich habe ihm das
natürlich gesagt er hat sich meinen
namen notiert und hat sehr freimütig mit
mir über die kritik der professoren
gesprochen und wir hatten davor schon
aus eigenen quellen gehört dass die
kritik im team geteilt wird und deshalb
haben wir das team auch kontaktiert und
dabei bleiben wir auch